what is this what's happening here
there's a couple of them you we've all
heard about you know the Jade egg the
Kegel a quintic Paltrow talks about
these and you know aunt her goop these
are you wait a minute wait a minute be
clear here Gwyneth Paltrow's talked
about putting a jade egg that women
should put one in their vaginas to help
improve pelvic floor strength but this
company that's developed these crystals
these are crystals called chakras so
chakra which are the energy centers in
the body
rugs meaning that they do have a shape
that is consistent with the shape of
something
phallic maybe on your body penile shaped
and these are crystals so this one's
amethyst this one is quartz clear quartz
and this one is black of the cities just
hold these up so that people get to see
them this is sort of a sick home
shopping netwerk well christmas is
coming and so you're gonna want to grab
these
grab these soon and these are all are
these to be let's just you know be
adults here are these to be placed
inside the body well yes they the
crystals what else you gonna do put
around a hot dog bun and somebody and
I'm asking for a question
I thought these had like a healing
energy and they would just be placed on
the body or be put near the body and
that's I think a legitimate if I've
looked at the shape of that thing you
don't know what to do it that you got
probably but the point being that
crystals are perfectly molecular
structures they do have energy and it
does help to balance the energy in your
body so you do putting them in
internally and also balancing your
feminine energy so okay pleasuring with
the balancing helps to intensify orgasms
and they're beautiful too and there is
healing energy to crystals I do believe
that okay and these also a good paper
weights right you can just use these you
could weigh things down you can have
these you can play spin the bottle and
then so many things you go nuts at
holidays crack nuts for everyone this
one moves
this one is what removes negative energy
white why does this one remove negative
energy it's black of City and that's the
crystal yep I don't see color right
I'm post-racial the doctor's airs
weekdays this thing is rolling towards
me look at it I got plans for you these
things are mine now we're gonna put
these over here okay
[Applause]
you